and then i'm gonna sit right here
oh look at the baby
[Applause]
babies we're so weird
hey guys welcome back to our channel we
are here in front of this mountain of
gifts that you guys were so generous to
gift this baby thank you so so so much
so we definitely wanted to sit down
and thank you guys and honestly we did
not expect
this much to come in like we just kind
of threw it out there like oh yeah
this is this is overwhelmingly like more
than what we expected and i'm just so
grateful for you guys thank you super
grateful we really feel the love but in
the description though we will list out
absolutely everyone that contributed and
saying thank you so anyway let's get
into this um there's this oogie bear
which is like to pick out not like
boogers and ear stuff from chewie they
said enjoy your gift been watching for
years now and i still love the vlogs
thank you so much we'll be thinking of
you every time we're picking our babies
boogers
this is a swaddle blanket and some
clothes this is from alicia so thank you
so much over here we have a baby carrier
this is from yenni she wrote
congratulations so we get to like
like play with the strapping the baby
too oh okay cool i have so much to learn
here like all this stuff is so foreign
to me all right this one's from kim hope
you enjoy the gifts and thank you for
sharing your journey with the world yes
it's a baby milestone blanket cool just
to like lay out the blanket and then see
the baby girl so this will actually be
um used a lot every month we'll be
taking a photo of baby in this blanket
so thank you so much kim because they
can't stand yet so you can't mark it on
the wall yet yeah you have to leave it
down this one's from tanya
congratulations on the new baby can't
wait for the birth video i have watched
you guys for a long time and enjoy your
videos and values oh thank you tanya are
we making a birth video there will be a
video about the birth yeah about the i
don't know how much we'll be sharing i
mean we live streamed our wedding yeah
it wouldn't be that far-fetched for some
live streamer
we'll be doing that okay um i'm gonna
want a little bit of privacy yeah some
privacy this one is so sweet so this is
from sophia said use this even when you
don't think you need it and these are
pre-moistened witch hazel pads
which is for postpartum like after like
delivering the baby and everything it's
kind of wild down there so you need
something and i've read that witch hazel
pads are like a lifesaver for
the healing process some witchcraft
magic to heal your table yeah and she
also gifted socks and bibs for the baby
oh cool
and she also gifted more postpartum
things this is so sweet thank you so
much sophia for thinking of me i love
you so much she gave me a peri bottle
and some postpartum supplements so this
is like
after you give birth you can't wipe down
there you have to rinse so this is for
rinsing squirts like getting your wisdom
teeth pulled out and getting the syringe
so like squeeze that out yeah that's
pretty much what's gonna happen to me
downstairs
in that department oh cool this one is
from michelle and it's baby bum what is
that sunscreen yeah sunscreen you want
me a little dolly here yeah a little toy
this one's from allison you two have
inspired me to travel the world oh
that's awesome i want to travel the
world some more too
when the safety's older though yeah yeah
and here's more clothes this one's from
michelle she wrote hi tiff casey and
isaac so happy for your new journey as
parents together i have been following
both of you so long and i remember when
you lived there in the old house anyway
enjoy your gift for the baby thank you i
love how these are all different uh age
ranges like this is zero to three months
and that's six to nine me
yeah not knowing anything i would not
have planned ahead like that no it's
super helpful this one is actually for
my friends helen and phil from wong fu
so they wrote here's the fewer loads of
laundry and keeping baby looking fresh
you're already blessed to have such
incredible parents little one can't wait
to meet you soon yay thank you helen and
phil congratulations to them too they
just had a baby boy and i've been
texting her a lot and like it's just so
cute they're now parents new parents i
love it congratulations on baby chan we
are over the moon and so excited to meet
the newest member of the chan clan i've
been following you guys on youtube for
quite some time now and happy to see
your family grow hugs from linda thank
you linda she gifted baby some wall arts
oh last time for the nursery all right
this one's from ariel and it is a
portable sound machine so we can carry
this around the house and here baby if
uh oh no that's that's a baby monitor a
sound machine you know how every night
we go to sleep with ocean sounds white
noise yeah white noise so this is like
for the baby to have like in the car or
when we move around but she also gifted
this one my first words in chinese
honestly i'm going to be learning
chinese because i'm like there's a lot
of stuff i don't know that's in here i'm
like perfect trying to brush up on my
cantonese yeah while the baby's learning
i'm trying to learn spanish with this
baby too like we're gonna try our best
to teach the baby spanish and chinese
and i'm gonna
really try to cue in on all the stuff
that they're learning and learning
i'm gonna learn too and we'll be as
fluent as the baby is yep and hopefully
the baby's flowing okay now this whole
pile here i don't know if you guys can
make it out but there's a ton of things
here so all of these gifts
are from catherine oh my goodness
catherine girlfriend thank you so much
catherine went ham yeah so catherine
said tiff and case thank you for being
so transparent and authentic with your
audience you guys are truly amazing may
you have a safe delivery and a speedy
recovery best wishes to your growing
family thank you so much catherine i
i'm like blown away with your love
towards this baby towards our family
thank you so much yeah she got more uh
yeah she had the rest of them vocabulary
words and she also got this little um
english to spanish
mini little library thank you so much
catherine super super super thoughtful
so this is from kelly and she said enjoy
your gift and this is actually a nursing
cover slash like poncho looking thing so
then whenever i'm nursing baby in public
or something like if i wanted to i can
have some privacy thank you to kelly
this one is from mallory congratulations
stephen case uh good luck with
everything you'll do amazing thank you
very much
what is this so this is a blanket with
moons and cute little bears like it just
goes with the theme nice so i'm looking
at everything and i'm like this is like
how i react to girl clothes and like
what is this what is this
relatively insane but different
this is from haley i hope you have a
safe delivery and a speedy recovery yay
thank you
so this is actually an infant like a
newborn support
lounger lounger slash pillow so like for
the baby not to have like a flat head
there's like a little hole in the pillow
for them to like lay on that's right
like a round head nice thank you so much
haley so this one is from anise anisia
that's a cool name yeah that's a really
cool name congrats praying for you guys
happiness
and these are like doggy bags but for
diapers so it's diaper bags oh very cool
and then this one is from lizette she
said hi i'm one of your youtube subs i'm
extremely happy for you guys i just
wanted to congratulate you and hopefully
these help some so this is a wipe
dispenser on the go wipe dispenser oh
cool yes that definitely helped and then
this gift is from kyla hi just so
excited for you guys to add another
member to your sweet little family i'm
currently in my 15th week oh
congratulations and my bp is a struggle
what's your blood pressure probably all
blood pressure yeah but watching your
vlogs keeps me excited for what's to
come love you love you too thank you
kyla appreciate it yeah so it's like
these two little toys this one too when
when i added to registry like this toy
here like the stacking of the rings is
usually like this big so when i saw this
i'm like oh my god how cute it's a mini
version i didn't even know that
for baby to hold on to when they're
smaller
yeah so thank you guys so much there was
also another box of wipes that came in
but this one didn't have
from who it was actually another
anonymous white giver thank you so much
from batman again yeah always batman if
someone's being suspicious or secretive
it's always batman with this guy yep all
right i think that's all of it and thank
you guys so much for sending all your
your generosity love and support i can't
wait to have baby use all this stuff and
learn chinese learn spanish and get
burgers picked
awesome well you know what like after
receiving all this stuff it really makes
me wanna
play with them and like see like use
them and see what it's like with the
baby what do you want to play with i
want to play with the wrap what do you
got there i have a bundled up bear baby
and this was done by my wonderful
husband so last night we were watching
this um like a course like the first few
weeks of a baby and so they were
teaching how to put on a diaper and how
to swallow swaddle a baby i have footage
of that that you're looking at right now
of my wonderful husband learning how to
put on a diaper and how to swallow
swallow swaddle
i do not want to swallow any babies
look how cute it's just done so well
like i'm so proud of you look at this
thank you thank you we're gonna have to
undo it no
oh can i ask you something how did it
make you feel watching me learn stuff oh
it made me like feel super warm and
fuzzy and my heart like exploded with
love because i'm like oh my god i'm cute
the love of my life is learning how to
take care of
someone that's gonna also be like very
important in my life that i love very
very much already so much and so i don't
know it's just
seeing that was super cute you never
would have expected that weirdo that you
met and started dating 10 years ago
would be the guy doing all this stuff
with you now oh it's so crazy and then
like i don't know just seeing you learn
because it's one thing to like see i've
already seen isaac like learn and
explore the world and like have so many
firsts and new experiences but to have
you have your own set of like first and
new experiences because it's just like
that's something that i've already
learned and gone through but then now
it's your turn you're my partner and i
love you so much really like
heartwarming so i don't know i loved
seeing it so i'm currently 34 weeks so
you guys know how far along i am for how
far this baby is and yeah i want to test
out the baby carriers with this bear oh
yeah what's the significance of this uh
baby bear this build-a-bear my mom uh
gifted this bear with an animal crusty
onesie that's something you and your mom
do together i don't know we share
actually we haven't played
since forever um anyway yeah and then
she added the baby's heartbeat
she got the baby's heartbeat in here
yeah look at casey's wonderful job of oh
i learned how to do the diaper too you
know look at all this very good look at
that poop will not come out i've
actually been taking the bear out of the
box occasionally what i didn't know that
yeah someone needs to record secretly
record you and i've just been going like
this and i'm like oh i can't wait to
hold you
this is like i'm practicing right now
and then my arm gets tired and i'm like
oh my god how am i gonna have this kid
in my arms if i'm getting tired with the
bear
and it literally weighs like nothing and
the kid weighs way more that's where the
mommy strength comes from you just you
just get that extra oomph that you need
to just do things i totally lost all my
mom's strength and my like my arms get
tired or i'm like what happened i used
to be like mega mom i could just do
anything but now i'm like oh my god i'm
out of breath my arm hurts like how am i
gonna do this with an actual
baby how am i gonna do it this is the
the newest one the coney or connie i
don't know how to pronounce it so
hopefully it fits because this goes by
sizes and i just guessed it looks really
fashionable yeah it actually looks like
kanye's lying
off the sweater i've already had a
breath
okay so then okay baby okay like this
and then okay take taking notes bring in
the baby
i don't know like this yeah i think this
is too tight i don't know how
our baby's gonna fit well once you give
birth don't you like
decompress a little bit that it's not
instantaneous thank you for calling me
no
giant blob
no because you're trying it on with a
pregnant belly i know yeah maybe it'll
fit better once after
this baby's out of here and into here
yeah this kid is
way too high up
my belly is in the way oh yeah imagine
you got pregnant immediately after
that'd be crazy a little bit dangerous
pregnancies that are less than 18 months
apart
they have a higher tendency to have like
more complications
lower birth weight
okay we'll wait a little bit so that's
this one
wait this one's really easy to put on
which i think it would be great for you
you want to try them sure this stuff is
like women's clothing i'll look at
anything like a it's like a regular top
that you haven't like where's the top
where's the bottom one
i don't even know oh yeah so it's
supposed to face so you do have it
correct which is the logo being
like that my short term memory is pretty
good that's good again in like a month
it's a female blouse
yeah with some midriff showing here
yeah very low cut i would say oh yeah
[Music]
way further down get down there
this is cool
all right give me a beer and let's turn
in the game wait wait you're not done
you need that
yeah to like keep the legs tight i guess
or
yeah i don't know like for added support
joining a karate tournament
[Laughter]
like that this is coffee yeah right i
feel really connected to the baby right
now yeah so this one there's a learning
curve okay so first of all you have to
fold it in half this looks way more
complicated i think i'll favor the other
one honestly honestly i had you in mind
for that one
[Music]
can't yeah to hold you
come up here you got to move up from
here to here
hi do you need to change your diaper
uh oh poopy diaper oh
poopy diaper
i sound so weird who are we we're
parents
i'm a new baby because we've been used
to being parents of a toddler of a
pre-teen of a teen we've never been
parents of uh
together of a infant true this is a new
role for two of us in our relationship
very true all right now let's set up
this play yard that leslie gave the baby
leslie and luis so ever since we uh ever
since christmas this has been our vr
yeah our vr space yeah we're about to
say goodbye to the vr space oh yeah we
didn't talk about that on our channel
we did not but yeah i gifted casey and
isaac a vr an oculus for christmas
no way it's so oculus is it oculus it
just says coolest i don't know yet i
don't know yet so yeah exactly that's
this is the space for that this is not
for you sir okay look at i'm so curious
so cute i think you snapped the sides
first
maybe
oh yeah
a new dad's struggle
all right here we go
you did it easy peasy hey this thing is
the heaviest part of the whole thing
yes
the mat
sweet and then it came with the with the
sheet and then i got a
yeah i do actually
so with isaac i actually slept in his
play yard that he had the crib that he
had by the time we lived with my mom
because we moved back with my mom when
isaac was nine months old for some time
and the crib was way too big to fit in
the bedroom so i actually slept in this
play yard but it was half the size of
this like
isaac's play yard was like because this
is a perfect square his was a rectangle
so i totally fit like right next to my
bed and i used to jump in there and put
him to sleep and then like slowly try my
best to crawl out and make sure not to
wake him up i don't think i can do that
with this baby i'm too too big now how
cute what are you doing you're gonna
swaddle the baby
there we go oh i put them down for
flight time yeah for a nap oh that would
be very dangerous it is yes you a baby
needs to be swaddled they can't have
loose blankets or pillows because
because of sins
i shouldn't have swaddled my hands
difficult practice makes perfect honey i
really want to build the bassinet
bassinet where is it right here yeah
it's over there the brown box can you
move over play pen oh i want to do this
you know how i love building things
[Music]
there we go
tada how do you like it how do you like
beer best than that so how many months
is this good for i just read it right
now it says it's like good foot to two
years old i think no it says up to six
months which is a lot
you're telling me a two-year-old can't
fit in here like i feel like like you
can literally put like a pretty big no
child in here they can fit but you
wouldn't want to put a bigger child in
here if they can stand up and fall out
the whole point that's why i'm a
first-time dad you're like let's put a
two-year-old in here yeah well save so
much money yeah let's build a high try
next which by the way just gifted baby
the high chair thank you so much thea
jess hey baby
you're cooking a lot like i've seen like
so many dads like like this is such a
cliche yeah like the dad building stuff
and like you're recording and then like
you're pregnant
just weird that i'm living through that
cliche right now yeah
it's your turn
[Music]
maybe you have to push the button or
something some sometimes it does that no
not that button the front button
oh my goodness big little baby
yeah that's where the baby's gonna be
[Applause]
so cute there we go
yeah you're gonna sit there and then i'm
gonna sit right here
oh look at the baby
we're so weird
i'm excited me too i'm super excited
[Music]
so
[Music]